[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the journalist
and broadcaster jenny clemen and the
deputy editor of conservative home henry
hill they'll be with us from now until
just before midnight so let's see what's
on some of those front pages for you now
well the eye hears that the office full
budget responsibility has told liz trust
that if she becomes prime minister she
won't be able to implement the tax cuts
she wants to because they'll cost
billions of pounds more than the
government has at its disposal
the guardian reports that bonuses for
the bosses of water companies went up by
20 last year even though they failed to
meet targets on sewage pollution
according to the star some pensioners
are finding it's cheaper and easier to
rent property in spain than it is to
face the cost of living here in the uk
the ft has word of mistrust's plans to
overhaul city regulatory practices if
she gets the top job
amid host pipe bans and reports of
sewage on beaches the metro rails
against water executives who between
them have banked nearly 25 million
pounds in the past year
the telegraph carries analysis
suggesting that delays to medical
treatments because of lockdown may now
be responsible for more deaths than the
current level of fatalities from covid
itself
with the story of an 87 year old man who
had to wait for 15 hours for an
ambulance to arrive while lying under a
makeshift shelter the mirror asks what
has become of our country
and the sun reveals that the queen's
granddaughter lady louise windsor has
got a job in a garden center
and reminded that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
programme you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by jenny
clemen and henry hill welcome to both of
you uh let's start with the
metro and uh water bosses their headline
feeling
flush take us into this story henry
so basically the water system has come
under an awful lot of scrutiny recently
and one of the things that's really
outraged people is the sheer volume of
sewage and pollution that is being
pumped into british were waterways and
coastal areas uh by these water
companies which are making many of them
unsafe to swim in that's actually been
the case in most of england's rivers for
a very long time tragically but it's now
getting to the point where many of the
beaches where people traditionally spend
the summer in august are also dangerous
to health and this is contrasted
water bosses have paid themselves
apparently vast sums of money now from
what i've seen of the story i couldn't
see a breakdown in what companies that
was because as far as i'm aware it's
actually two water companies eastern and
southeastern or two of those which have
massively overshot their pollution
targets and the rest of them are doing
an awful lot better so i would be
interested to see whether or not the
current regulatory system has penalized
those two whereas the others have taken
money but either way it does seem to be
the case that people who are overseeing
a system that isn't working properly and
is failing the public are nonetheless
being allowed to take home
massive bonuses
yes sir the article saying that
executives at britain's 22 water firms
received 24.8 million last year
including 14.7 million in bonuses
benefits and incentives jenny
yes the average pay
of the people who head up these water
companies
is
670 000 pounds and uh the metro calls
this a scandal and i think it is a
scandal uh i received a text from uh my
water company uh saying it was going to
be a host pipe ban and presenting it as
a kind of fate accompli you cut you
can't control the weather is is the what
the uh the uh water companies have been
saying but the thing is uh you can
control leaks you can invest in pipes
and infrastructure you can
invest in the sewage system so there
isn't contamination from from sewage
overflows and you have a situation here
where bonuses are rising a hundred
thousand pounds per executive whilst we
swim in sewage it it is it's outrageous
yeah they quote liberal democrat
environmental spokesman tim farren as um
saying that host pike bands could have
been avoided this summer if these water
company ceos bothered to invest in their
rusting pipes rather than stuffing
profits in their pockets uh making it
abundantly clear and his thoughts on the
matter let's move on to the
guardian um and the same story the water
bosses bonuses going up by 20 amid the
pollution um and
what will will irk many people reading
these headlines is that while their
their water bills are going up the
companies
are wasting
so much water we read henry
yeah i think it's actually important
though to remember that it's not just
the companies that are at fault here
water is a very very heavily regulated
sector and the government and the
regulator have to take a share of
responsibility because most a lot of
this country's water infrastructure was
basically built by the victorians and
instead of going to the vast expense of
digging it all up and replacing it what
we've basically done in quite a
water-rich country normally is that the
government and the regulator have made a
decision that it is more cost efficient
to simply pump more water through the
system and accept a certain amount of
loss to leaks than it is to to do the
alternative and for the most part with
again some glaring exceptions most of
the water companies are within or close
to
the amount of leakage which is allowed
by the regulator now the regulator is
toughening that up the regulator is also
toughening up quite rightly the amount
of pollution that's allowed in the
rivers i think they're pushing it up to
zero which is where it should have been
all along i think but this is not just a
question of evil companies there's
definitely some of that i don't think
these bonuses are justifiable but the
the bigger questions about our water
infrastructure is something that
ultimately the government has to answer
to thames water for example has been
trying to build these we talked about
host pipe bands thames water has been
trying to build 150 million cubic meter
reservoir in abingdon for more than 10
years the government should have got
that built by now it's because we don't
have that that there is a host pipe ban
in place now so yes the companies do
need to be cracked out on where they're
crossing the line but regulator and the
government also need to take their share
of responsibility for where we've ended
up
and jenny it's not just the the abundant
leaks it's also that the sewage releases
and data
has been quoted here there have been
recent discharges in cornwall cumbria
devon essex lancashire lincolnshire
northumberland and sussex and people are
having to stay out of the water stay
away from the beaches
at a time of year when so many families
are going to the beaches i was in
cornwall
last year last week on a beach that is
now uh full of human waste it's
absolutely disgusting and even though
the cost the bosses water companies are
saying you know what is going into the
sea might be uh 97 98 99
rain water i bet they they wouldn't want
to get the one percent of whatever it is
uh in in their faces um it's completely
outrageous if it's as henry says no it
may be that a certain number of leaks
are allowed it may be that um this uh
sewage overflow is the system that
that's allowed to happen under our
current regulation but what does that
say about the way that we organize
ourselves that we we build in massive
amounts of waste at a time where there
is a you know water shortages all over
the world or we accept that there's
going to be sewage floating in the water
uh a certain number of times a year we
we should be better than this and and we
should be investing more and and
and not allowing uh the bosses of these
companies to have pay increases of over
a hundred thousand pounds a year whilst
we swim with feces
henry let's move on to
another story in the eye and it looks as
if liz trust becomes prime minister
she's going to be told that there's not
going to be enough money to carry out um
everything that she wants to do
yeah this has been one of the big
question marks facing liz truss's
leadership campaign for the conservative
party from the beginning she her whole
pitch in contrast to that of rishi
sooner is that she wants to go really
aggressive on tax cuts tens of billions
of pounds worth of tax cuts which she
says will stimulate growth now she's
received a lot of pushback from that
from people who are arguing that they're
inflationary but there's also just the
simple fact as the as the obr says that
the government doesn't have the fiscal
headroom to deliver these tax cuts plus
the various public spending commitments
she's made on the campaign such as
northern powerhouse rail whilst at the
same time inflation is corroding all of
the other government spending budgets
including things like the nhs so she
needs to be asked are you going to
borrow for this money that's going to be
incredibly expensive or are you going to
be making big spending cuts elsewhere if
she is she hasn't spelt them out and i
think that was going to happen quite
quickly if as it now as now looks likely
liz trust wins the conservative party
leadership election is that she's going
to have to make some very difficult
decisions when this optimistic slightly
reaganish approach to tax cuts runs
headlong into the reality of the fiscal
situation that the united kingdom finds
itself in
but jenny this obr warning's not going
to make any difference to her her
fortunes is it i mean at this stage
she's on schedule to be prime minister
this is something like 32 points ahead
in the polls uh she is the booster-ish
cakes johnsonis optimist candidate
saying that she can deliver growth
through tax cuts and and solve the cost
of living crisis uh that way i mean
this
i i think supporters of rishi sunak will
be happy with this front page because it
supports his position as being uh
someone who's trying to be realistic the
one leveling with the public not
promising the earth um but maybe that's
what uh what the conservative party
members who are going to be voting uh
are looking for still some optimism and
uh you know we're you know being
prepared to kick the can down the road
in terms of uh facing the reality
yes the the poll of tory members gives a
there's trust 66 support to rishi soon
as 32
at the moment just to update everybody
on that uh let's have a look finally at
um just before the break i think we've
got time to look at the the telegraph
and this story um about medical
consequences of of lockdown actually
being far worse than covid itself
henry
yeah so this is this is um this is quite
a slow burning story but it has been
building up basically there were
obviously trade-offs when the nation
went into lockdown we didn't know the
lethality of kobit 19 there were there
were lots of at-risk groups and so the
government shut everything down and shot
people in their homes and all the rest
of it now that did work in suppressing
the virus i think it's quite clear that
it saved lives on that metric but the
what we now have is a growing body of
evidence that things such as delayed uh
medical treatments most obviously but
also just the long-term impact on
people's health in terms of more people
taking up smoking more people sort of
gaining weight and losing track of their
fitness and all kinds of other metrics
these are adding up to suggest that the
long-term impact of that extended period
of time in lockdown has been hugely
damaging to the nation's health which
when you think about it makes perfect
sense i don't think anybody would have
said that locking locking people up for
two years or you know the best part of
two years would have been good for them
but this obviously what's done is done
but it does raise a question of if we
have another pandemic or if we have a
resurgence of another variant of coping
19 with this information to hand is it
going to change the decision that
ministers make and the public health
experts make because previously we
didn't know either the lethality of
covert or really what the consequences
of an extended lockdown would be now
that we are getting a better picture of
what both of them look like the question
is next time do we do the same thing
again and the more of this evidence that
comes up the stronger will be the case
for doing something else yes and the
stats showing that a thousand more
people than usual are dying each week
from conditions other than coronavirus
jenny
yes i mean the daily telegraph is
looking about delays and deferment to
treatment for cancer heart disease and
diabetes but there was a report about a
month ago about levels of excessive
drinking linked to the pandemic and how
we're going to be seeing excess deaths
for for years to come because of this
look lock down
well we know that it worked um but
it will take a generation to work out i
mean it was a a hammer that cracked a
nut we need to work out how big a hammer
was was necessary it was a very big
hammer perhaps we could have had a
smaller lock down and and saved some of
those excess tests but you know you have
to you have to go back to the the vision
that we had in 2020 which is not the
vision that we have now now we know that
a vaccine could be developed it was
developed quickly and that there was a
light at the end of the tunnel back then
we had absolutely no choice but to keep
away from each other but yes it will
take a generation
to see whether or not the damage from
lockdown was greater than the potential
damage from covet indeed jenny and henry
thank you very much for the moment we
are going to take a break coming up uh
would you use a self-driving car
apparently you may soon have the chance
on uk roads we'll be discussing that
next
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me jenny clement and
henry hill um let us take a look at the
financial times uh the picture there
of uh the turkish president the u.n
secretary general and vladimir zelinski
and they're discussing the uh region
nuclear power plant and the shelling
that that's gone on there both sides
accusing the other jenny
this is very interesting because uh
you have uh
a russia with a veto in the un so no
matter what happens in these uh
discussions there is only so much that
gutierrez can do you have erdogan who is
enjoying his uh his powerful position
here he is one of the few people that's
still talking to vladimir putin this
allows him to um
to have quite a lot of power in all of
this this is his first face-to-face uh
meeting uh with zalensky uh as you say
both ukraine and russia accusing each
other of of shelling the power plant and
as much as gutierrez may say that you
know there needs to be absolutely no
shelling around in that area um you know
his powers are very limited and and and
very constrained
uh at the moment so i'd say that the
person who's um
who's really winning in this scenario is
actually erdogan who has a lot of power
and legitimacy now in his in his role as
mediator in the ukraine conflict yes and
he's quoted as saying we don't want to
live through another chernobyl
henry
yeah well i think i think one of the one
of the signs that 2022 was getting off
to a really bad start was in february
when a wikipedia entry called the battle
of chernobyl um appeared for the first
time that was when russian forces
occupied the power plant and it seems
they've done so again and there have
been allegations effectively that what
they're doing is they're using the plant
as a shield by launching uh artillery
attacks from the site uh meaning that if
the ukrainians try to take those
artillery out they're risking the power
plant and everything else which is a
sign i think of just the
extraordinary lengths to which the
russian armed forces have proven that
they're prepared to go
after they failed to roll over ukraine
in the early days and weeks of the war
which they and i think many other people
were expecting now you know erdogan is i
don't think any western powers idea of
you know a first a first-rate guy rush
turkey uh his regime in turkey is
problematic in many respects but he does
now have an extremely important role to
play because he is one of the people
who's still talking to putin he's
actually still buying an awful lot of
putin's oil turkey is a big gap in the
sanctions regime that the west has set
up to try and [ __ ] the war effort so
it's important that we we say that when
we when he poses as a peacemaker but
nonetheless if we assume as i think we
probably should that there will have to
be a negotiated settlement of some sort
at some point uh a regional power broker
like erdogan
if he is more likely to make that happen
than so much the better
jenny we've just got time for this last
story in the telegraph and according to
the transport secretary the first
self-driving cars will be here
next year would you be driven in one
well it's not what you think it is
jillian i hate to say there's a lot of
hype about self-driving cars these
particular cars would have automatic
lane and speed control so it's not the
sort of thing where you lie back with
your feet up watching a movie whilst
you're being driven around uh the thing
that really interests me about this
coverage is that the law commission has
drawn up proposals whereby drivers who
they're not called drivers they're
called users in charge
would not be prosecuted for careless
driving or for speeding or for running a
red light if their car did it this is
way in the future when we have these
properly automated cars
and instead it would be the developer or
the manufacturer who who would be liable
which does seem crazy that you could be
in a car having a car accident and elon
musk or uber whoever or speeding along
above the speed limit and not be held
liable for it um interesting that is the
future though jenny and henry thank you
very much for the moment we'll see you
in the next hour